something from the comics was
introducing uh
melissa's girlfriend and just because
you sort of layer in the fact that she's
bisexual and it's just like
wonderful little character detail that
that's just sort of in it i'm wondering
if that was to come to the show if if
that's something
that was important to you from the
beginning or is it something that
because again i i just think it's really
lovely the way it just sort of
is i love the idea that modoc is this
super villain
but having a bisexual daughter doesn't
phase him
that's not a problem to him so i'm
wondering if that was something
conversations you had
for season one something you always plan
to reveal in season two or anything like
that
yeah it was something we always kept
trying to get to in season one
the problem is season one is so much
about modoc and everyone's relationship
to modoc that we never really get to see
melissa's life outside of um him
and you know there was moments where we
tried to work it in like you know the
pilot
she holds up a dead boyfriend and we're
like i don't want to like
introduce this relationship and then the
first thing we do is murder
the person you know and you know there
were lines and stuff
that were always in there so um i was
like i want to tell the story until
right
and i was very annoyed that we didn't
get to it was just kind of you're
constantly cutting things for time
and you know and really her story with
modoc was about them
you know and not her life outside of it
but it was always something that was
like god i wanted to get to that
well in a really like lovely normalizing
it way
it he it wasn't mentioned to me at first
while we were recording
um you know and i think a lot of the
focus of season one is on the family and
their sort of dynamics and
hopefully if we get to do more we'll get
to dive more into
you know the personal lives of
especially the kids
um because i think in season one we just
kind of more see them in the in the
space of the family
representation is very important for me
in in the show
so we were so happy that we were able to
kind of canonize it in the comic
and um and so was melissa fumer was so
excited i actually bought that page for
her in regards to her
sexuality i you know we did a similar
storyline on brooklyn nine-nine with the
rosa character so i
got to experience firsthand how
meaningful that was
for i think it was the first time on
network television that a character said
i'm bisexual like just said the words
and i to see the impact that had on
people particularly young people
was just incredibly moving and you just
see
the importance of it so i'm so proud i
was thrilled when jordan told me that
you know they had planned to make
melissa bye and that it was in the
comics and if we get another season we
get to dive into that more
because particularly she's a teenager
you know and how confident
and and sure of herself she is you know
that's that could be a powerful thing
for a kid to see
you know to just be like oh i'm there's
i am completely fine like you know i am
who i
am and there is nothing wrong with that
we wanted to to showcase a modern
family that feels real you know and i'm
in an interfaith
relationship or marriage and that leads
to a lot of interesting stories and the
same thing of
having um you know a mixed family where
modoc is jewish and uh you know um
uh jody is mexican and having uh
a son having a bar mitzvah being able to
tell my story you know that was just
something we really wanted to do because
there are so many just all white you
know animated families and the last
thing we wanted to do was kind of add
to that as opposed to be able to create
a family that feels new and
and different and unique and kind of
representative what
families look like now the thing about
what we do that
um really speaks to me and i feel
that i just always want to be like in
service of because
stories can really impact people in
really deeply meaningful personal ways
so
yeah i i hope we get to do more so we
can dive into that
i would love to just be able to now you
know not
leave monica behind but introduce these
characters that you
love them that you're you want to go on
journeys with them into their own worlds
as well outside of how they relate to
modoc so that was something
that we absolutely want to tackle in
season two